I got full blood labs in June and then in December total cholesterol. Good. So it's a little chat
on cholesterol talked about this a lot before, but one of the worst things for cancer patients
having low cholesterol. So cholesterol is your precursor for vitamin D, as the sun hits your
skin. It changes a chemical in your skin called seven hydroxy cholesterol, which is derived from
circulating cholesterol. So one of the dangers of people going on a lipitor and cholesterol
lowering drugs is that they end up with a vitamin D deficiency because they can't convert the sun,
the vitamin D that they normally get from the sun into vitamin D so they don't get vitamin D for
the sun. Besides the fact that lipitor damage is your liver in so many ways too. HDL is
delved LDL, still not the same glucose. Yeah, you're still fine in glucose range. A1C, great insulin
fantastic, alkaline, I think that's alkaline phosphatase, Ast, ALT. So everything else is looking great.
High sensitivity CRP is really a function of inflammation. C-reactive protein is really
the breakdown of inflammatory cytokines in your liver. A few years ago they came up with the test
called the high sensitivity CRP to try to get more specific on cytokines that could be affected
in your vascular system, but it's really not that specific. Everything else looks good.
Fairytid, I would be concerned about fairytid. What fairytid is really high, it's actually inflammatory
blocker. So everything else is great. All right, T3, if the only thing it was done is your TSH and T3,
it's not a complete thyroid panel. So you'd really want to get a T4 or T3 uptake, reverse T3, TPO,
antibody test done too to really get a good picture of T3. T3 and TSH can change throughout the day
and day by day too, so that's not enough to diagnose thyroid issues.